[Music]
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv vales contagious
this world of entrepreneurs we get no
value to ha run homie look what I become
I'm I'm the
one so you know what's tough to do think
about this for a second here folks
imagine you trying to write one book
it's already hard to do right then think
about writing a book that becomes a New
York Times bestseller okay that's hard
to do then think about writing a book
bashing philosophy supported by the New
York Times newspaper and you still win
the New York Times bestseller then
imagine doing that 13 times and your
name is Anne couter and you're invited
to all these shows and you have
relationships with people who like you
hate you love you complicate she's able
to befriend people that don't agree with
her philosophies not an easy thing to do
uh she gets under people skin within
seconds if she chooses to just recently
we'll talk about this one here with a
man you may recognize uh uh Donald J
Trump you guys had an exchange on
Twitter and uh uh uh truth social she is
a conservative political commentator
author legal analyst a writer columnist
for New York Times and uh you know
coulter's first book High crimes and
misdemeanor the case against Bill
Clinton she wrote a book called in Trump
We Trust slightly changed recently she
sold over 5 million copies and her
columns are read by millions and more
and couter how are you great great to be
here it's great to have you here it's
very good to have you here also you
forgot my substack that's my newest
thing okay I got sick of the censorship
on Twitter so now you can read all my
column see my podcast videos all at an
culture. subs.com are they still yeah
thanks Elon yeah oh wow Elon hasn't done
anything to help you no and I mean this
kind of annoys me about I mean he's
wrecked it in like 17 different ways but
one of them is he makes this big show of
there's going to be no censorship and
then he brings back like
Nazis gee thanks good favor for us but
wrong with Nazi look I believe in free
speech but he won't bring back um I'll
just start in with the most outrageous
things but people like um um what is it
um Jared Taylor um who write he he was
raised in Japan so he speaks um he's
very gentlemanly very I mean he's the
opposite of a Nazi in that way but he
only writes about race that's the issue
and he writes about it honestly I mean
it was reviewed his book um I forget
what it was his red book was reviewed in
the National Review favorably when it
came out years ago um but because he
writes only about race he's still
banned from Twitter and I am 100% still
Shadow band I've got more than two well
what happened was and sorry and then
I'll end it um I had 2.1 million
followers 2018 or 19 this is be before
Elon suddenly one overnight I lost
200,000 followers and for the next from
seven years I went from zero to 2.1
million from that moment on I've never
gotten another Twitter
follower from 21 million no they they
took me down by by a couple hundred wow
so who who else within uh the new
Twitter that elon's running what else
are you not happy with what he's doing
since that's what you started changing
the name that is the most moronic I mean
you're the entrepreneur this is it's
like changing the name of
Kleenex what on Earth and we all still
call it Twitter yeah X is stupid I
always feel like I'm closing it down
when I get when I click on the X to get
it to reload it looks like the the
button shut the screen down interesting
but besides the fact that it's known
worldwide you wouldn't change the name
of Google you wouldn't change the name
of Facebook you complete and the
other biggest thing he did which is
utterly is he didn't understand
what the blue check mark was that was so
and I did it just this week and I
thought oh crap is this really Matt
Gates because I wanted to tweet
something to Matt Gates and so I started
to put in at at Matt Gates and it used
to be well there's a blue check mark yep
that's really Matt Gates and I just
thought I was screwed I'm not even
checking screw you Elon cuz you don't
know you pay
$10 the point of the blue check mark I
had to to get my Twitter account I'm
really not shutting up but by the way to
be fair what I liked about the blue
check mark on what he did he wanted to
eliminate Bots that was his way of
getting rid of bots and not wanting to
rely on advertisers to get money so he
doesn't have to go get all the
advertising money that you know Twitter
used to rely on okay we'll get back to
the Bots thing in one sentence to get my
Twitter account they had to throw off a
fake an cter that's the purpose of the
blue check mark am I responding to the
real Chelsea Handler the real Bob Dole
or is this a fraud now we don't know and
who cares about Bots and how does a bot
get a blue check mark actually that
would be a good thing a bot isn't going
to get a blue check mark are you uh
ready to start your account on Truth
social when is that
starting I've thought about um what is
it um Zuckerberg's thing or threads you
don't even know the name that's how
irrelevant and the other one is that
what's that semaphor or something I
don't know what but you see this is the
problem and this is why I don't even
care you probably know about the major
Free Speech case recently where they
found the and the discovery was
unbelievable how the Biden
Administration was putting pressure on
Twitter Facebook the rest of them to
shut down well you know these brilliant
virologists and epidemiologists the
great barington declaration guys and
wouldn't let them tell the truth about
vaccines and by the way they're not
antivaccine um about shutdowns etc etc
um and it was really unbelievable how
the Biden Administration was directly
saying it wasn't like a subtle oh a
mafia thing no it was what the f you
doing take this down right away
including a Jill Biden parody account
they made them take down um I don't
think you need the government pushing
these private companies for this to be a
First Amendment violation because why am
I not going to go to seor or or whatever
that other thing is because this is the
Public Square now it's a public utility
no you shouldn't have the right to
censor anyone you shouldn't have the
right to censor anyone with Twitter okay
so go back to it the the so you said the
blue check mark the the Bots says who
cares about the Bots right well the Bots
were a big part of manipulating and
propaganda because you know I there were
companies who can hire that has a
million Bots to get a tweet to get
100,000 tweets to create momentum but
it's it's fake and what makes it look
like it's so much more interesting so to
eliminate that where you're like yeah
this is probably a bot versus no this is
an account cuz a person's paying for it
I guess what he could do bots could pay
for it Bots could pay for it but not
times 100,000 accounts if you think
about that also I don't think I don't
think the blue check mark does anything
about bot but I'll come back to whether
I care about Bots which I really don't
um but the blue check mark
um if somebody doesn't already have a
million followers they shouldn't be
getting a blue check mark you have to be
Bob Dole um Bill Mah you have to be
somebody we've heard of that's the point
so different colors so maybe keep it
maybe keep it different colors if you
pay for you could do that right if you
paying for it it's maybe yellow check
mark whatever and I know they're doing
right now nonprofit whatever government
organization and keep the blue checkm
Mark protected so you know that is the
account cuz it's true because you can
look at an cter par parody
right such and such parody account and
it almost looks
real account went viral and blew up so
so what what have you been doing lately
obviously it's been a lot of uh U
changes that happened since you went on
Bill Maher and you told Bill Mah that
that you were the first person that's
like yeah who's going to win today I
think who was to your right she said Joy
who was uh joyan Reed she was there and
then another fellow with a weird looking
shirt that was supporting Marco Rubio
and Gutierrez who was supporting I want
to say he was talking about Jeb Bush
even though he's a Democrat himself and
you said yeah this is the one can you
just play this from the beginning you
were the first right this just play this
is how start announc watch this okay
here we are and which Republican
candidate has the best chance of winning
the general election of the declared
ones right now Donald Trump look at that
look you knew
it
look
so of all the I Told You So is does this
rank at the highest for you or it's
pretty good I I just remember thinking
at the time and days afterwards liberals
always think that derisive laughter ha
we proved you wrong and I was thinking
well we don't know what's happened yet
yeah yeah you saw that Joy Reid who's
one of the talking heads on MSNBC
probably the most liberal of all the
Liberals on MSNBC literally lost her
mind she couldn't even think for a
second well she looked at like she was
nuts like crazy and Bill Maher you've
seen him you know sort of stay centered
if you want to kind of call you notice
he doesn't laugh he knows me he knows
exactly well you just laugh and you
don't wait for facts when you don't care
about facts anyway right well one of the
things I respect about Bill Mars he's
famously said it's okay for you to hate
Trump you can't hate the people that
have voted for Trump oh good for him I
agree with that where do you stand on
that I'm starting to hate him now uh
Trump or Bill Mar people voted for the
people who still support him well um
it's funny because I I used to say I
didn't know he had said that but I used
to say that when Trump was president and
not building the wall not deporting
illegal aliens and doing well it was the
presidency of Jared Kushner um and Paul
Ryan he governed exactly like Jeb Bush I
still would write in trumpy trust
because he was the first candidate
saying the things I wanted a candidate
to say um and I keep I mean I've given
it to to Republicans saying this was the
greatest campaign in United States
history do what's in this book it's a
great book because it describes sorry I
guess I shouldn't say that but it
describes what was so great about about
Trump not listening to the political
Consultants not giving us the stupid
cliches not bringing his wife up on
stage not talking about Reagan Reagan
Reagan Reagan it was I will build a wall
he was the only one who directly went to
policy trade wall no more more stupid
Wars um that's what I've been waiting to
V vote for my entire life now if he come
out at 2: a.m. the night he won and
Hillary people are all crying crying
that was so great I sometimes just watch
that over
[Laughter]
again woohoo we won and then had a heart
attack and died that would have been the
best thing that could have happened to
this country because he had proved he
had done everything good he was ever
going to do with that campaign and Pence
would have been afraid to betray his
supporters no Trump oh no I'm not going
to build the wall we'll move the embassy
though you guys should be happy with
that so uh speaking of Bill Mah so so
you write this book in Trump we in Trump
We Trust right so you start off you go
on Bill Mah you say Trump's gonna win
everybody loses their minds he there's a
book he wrote that I was introducing at
rallies before that you were everywhere
you were he was banned he was banned
from no he wasn't banned from Fox I was
banned from Fox for supporting Trump but
sometimes they'd be forced to put me on
when they were covering a trump rally
because I'd be speaking before him
that's how much I was for him yeah and
then you even write this book in Trump
We Trust right so okay so you're fully
on the camp this is August 2023 which is
what three months before you know 10
weeks before election time that's coming
up and then he wins and then you're
right and everybody says she knew
something we didn't know then slowly but
surely you're not happy with what he's
doing the comment you just made right
now the best thing could have been he
would had a heart attack and that was it
because that was the highest Milestone
he didn't build a wall he did you know
Tel Aviv to Jerusalem he didn't you know
how about us how about us how about us
at what point did you start turning and
saying wait a minute what happened to
all the promises you made 10% tariff
Mexico 20 billion you could have gone
that money Etc at what point did you say
wait a minute what is going on here um
before he was sworn in I was getting
nervous we all were but still you know
you want to be constructive and so I was
gentle gentle gentle I famously though I
told no one I'm a vault I can talk to to
politicians and they never have to worry
about I won't even tell my friends um
because this has to be you know private
and I used to talk to him a lot um
during the campaign he hung on my every
word I could I could text something to
Corey and it would be coming out of his
mouth 30 seconds later um but I showed
up in Washington in fact I had lunch
with Michael isakov that um very good
but liberal reporter Washington Post in
Newsweek and I went straight from lunch
to the White House and I never sat down
I just stood right at the edge of the
Resolute desk and yelled at him for 15
minutes saying exactly what you just
said you are not doing what you promised
you got elected on the wall you're doing
nothing on the wall you're doing nothing
on anchor babies you're doing nothing on
trade with Mexico remember it took him
like two years to do that even even to
end that um and I didn't start using the
f word first but once it
started oh it it they heard it through I
mean I don't know who how the pre the
press found out I don't know like a
month later and it was published and I
thought it actually could have been
anyone in the West Wing because we were
yelling at one another so much oh wow
this this is how much uh after how long
I think it was February oh shoot immed
17 yeah so it didn't okay so now when
he's putting his team together uh were
you and him directly talking or was it
mainly through Corey during the election
no D um oh after he was elected i'
actually every once in a while I'd speak
to him directly during the campaign but
when he was you know standing up giving
a speech that was when I tell him you're
in New Hampshire talk about immigration
they're opioids opioids huge huge issue
um and then he'd be saying it um and by
the way I don't think I've ever told
anyone that before but screw him wow
I'll tell the truth now um and then I
talked to him a fair bit on the phone
basically for the first year in
office and you know the the way he tries
to win you over I I I met with him
immediately after the speech where he
was bragging about the size of his hands
and I said to him um I happen to be in
Flor I drove to marago I was waiting for
him it's him Cory Hope come in and
they're eating dinner Hicks uh and I
said look I'm the only person losing
money trying to put you in the white
house you're going to listen to me no
more bragging about the size of your
penis at
debates and what he does is he tries to
win you over by you know Charming you
and giving you oh you're losing money
here I'm going to give you something
worth $200,000 a membership to Mara
Lago as if I'd ever set foot unless I am
yelling at the president or president to
be
um um well in that case it might come in
handy yeah right right right could have
get right through the front door no
waiting oh sorry okay so that that was
quick so okay so from you're saying the
so the last time you and him actually
had a phone call was when was it in 17
no no no we kept talking then he called
me and bragged about um he bragged about
how even the liberal media remember when
he bombed Syria and it turned out it
wasn't chemical
weapons oh man what happened to no more
Wars so you know ianka cried kids died
so he starts bombing Syria and remember
the liberal media loved it oh they love
when we bomb foreign
countries um and he called me and told
me how oh can you see all the great PR
I'm getting and I said this this isn't
what you want on Sir this isn't it was
supposed to be the wall it was supposed
to be our country why are you getting us
more involved in the Middle East now um
and throughout that time when he was
picking his team he' he'd try to you
know win me over because I didn't like
some of his picks why you they weren't
consistent with what he ran on um and I
was pretty gentle about it um but he'd
always like offer me something well I
could do something oh you're not on Fox
you know rert calls me four times a day
and I I distinctly remember I said to
him I don't care about Fox I don't care
about my career just hire Chris kobak
for Homeland Security that's all I want
you to do and he didn't and by the way
the wall would have gotten built and we
would be done with anchor babies and
dreamers and the rest of it if he had
hired Chris so and for this is your
world you've been in it for a while
you've been you've been relevant for a
long time with the issues you talk about
when it comes on to picking your team
okay when you become a president it's
different if you're in the world right
so for example if your name is Bush you
know Ste Steph Schmidt was here last
week and he said a very interesting
thing about the fact that when he sat
down in a meeting with uh uh President
Bush and Carl Ro and all those guys are
there and president asking and says
who's the best political strategist in
this room and Stephen looks at the the
President says Hey president I would say
Carl Ro he says wrong it's me say my
entire family I've been in politics I've
been this my dad Grandpa so he made a
point say I know what's going on he says
I don't think John ker is going to win
it's because he's an but at the
same time we have to be thinking about
all these things he's saying right okay
so Bush puts a team together but he's
been in that world but he kind of knows
who to hire right you know if your name
is Obama maybe you don't know everybody
because you're only a one-term senator
so the best comparison I can make to
Trump would be an Obama because again
you're not in it right everybody else
prior to him director of CIA senior you
know Ronald Reagan two-time governor you
know D you can kind of go
to if he gets reelected okay cuz he's
right now ahead by 40 50 60 points it
will never happen so you're saying it'll
never happen Okay but go back to it when
he did what should he have done with his
team okay in an ideal situation should
it be let me bring somebody from the you
know mainstream side to see what you
think about it let me bring some people
from the political side but who do you
trust when you're in a position like
that that you've never been in that
environment right well first of all um I
want to say those words have never been
used in combination before Stephen
Schmidt said an interesting
thing you've made a very good argument
for for and I've heard I've heard people
make variations of and you do it very
well better than I've heard before that
well he doesn't know this isn't his
world he's in real estate um but no I'm
sorry he knew who to trust when he was
campaigning he knew if I listen to these
people I'm going to be popular I'm going
to get cheers here I'm going to get
votes besides me um Jessica vaugh
basically anything Breitbart said um
Chris kobak is the one who was advising
him on how you get Mexico to pay for it
you tax remittances oh that was another
thing that I yelled at him in the Oval
Office about um it's very easy to get
Mexico to pay for the wall maybe he
didn't understand it hire Chris kobak so
you know for for 16 months during the
campaign he knows if I listen to these
500 people I'm going to be huge I'm
going to be so popular now I'm president
I know I'll hire my son-in-law a liberal
Democrat from New York and C one
questions Al so and and because one of
my biggest before we do that I I want to
get into this uh uh a little bit deeper
but let me first go to our sponsor
because I have to do my job right or
else I don't have a job they fire sorry
so today's sponsor is American Harford
gold uh if if you've uh uh heard what
I've talked about over the years I've
always had physical gold uh since day
one I've been in the financial industry
since the day before 9/11 series 7 all
these things that I've done but I've
always always been a fan of having
physical gold not a big percentage but a
small percentage and in 2022 when you
look at data central banks globally
bought a record
1136 tons of gold when they do that you
got to pay attention according to Bank
of international settlement over 90% of
central banks are working on a cbdc
American hardford Gold can ship physic
physical gold or silver directly to your
door and they can all set up a gold Ira
if you have retirement funds you can
roll over your money into it they'll
show you how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts by diversifying your
portfolio with physical gold and silver
American Harford gold has a f uh festar
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from Better Business Bureau tell them
my S you and they'll give you up to
$5,000 of free silver on your first
order click on a link below or call
866939 6984 again 866939 6984 or text
pbd to
65532 go ahead Vinnie so um so and so
and with with the border which is one of
our big things and you could see you
know what's happening right now it's
it's blatantly obvious what the left is
doing how hard was it that he made those
promises but the left from the beginning
was doing you know a coordination with
the media racist you're racist Mexico
this that that how hard was it for him
to make that promise and I think he
actually did believe in it but how hard
did the left make it for him to keep
that because everything was about race
and how how how much do that affect them
well I write about that in in in Trump
We Trust I think it actually helped
Trump um what you want to do and I think
Dan santis is doing this a little bit
there are some other things he could do
it on um what you want to do is take an
issue that's like 80% popular with
voters but 90% unpopular with the media
that's immigration I've never seen an
issue like this where the public is way
on one side and all of the elites
politician and the media on the other
side so he takes the position and then
the media end up amplifying it for him
he looks Brave when in fact he's like
pandering by by coming out for the wall
it actually really really helped him to
be called a racist I mean that that
Mexican rapist thing I didn't actually
support him when I said that on Bill
Maher because I thought he was going to
back down he always struck me as you
know kind of an chowderhead O'Reilly
type and know whichever way the elites
want me to go and amazingly two weeks
later he didn't backed down and I
thought well okay he may be an utter
vulgarian but this is what I've been
waiting to vote for and he never backed
down and I think the media hating him
for that and calling him a racist for
that just made his supporters it was
like tensil steel and you uh we started
off the segment talking about your viral
clip on Bill Maher I'll give you the
utmost credit you nailed it boom you
know you were on Bill Mah recently again
this is within the last couple years
that first clip was obviously in 2015 he
said look you voted for him you
convinced you called it you called your
shot Babe Ruth style uh he said
obviously jokingly uh but now you're
finding out it turns out he's just some
big fat lying con man right what was
your first clue so break that down what
what was your first clue that he
actually in your words lied to you in
the American well in my defense I always
knew that was a
possibility I grew up in Connecticut so
I've been watching this guy Trump since
I was a kid and he isn't an utter arist
vulgarian really wants the I mean just
every bad adjective you can imagine so
that was possible but again he was the
only one saying the right things you
know what um the mayor of New York right
now um mayor Eric Adams he is basically
the same thing who else would you vote
for he was talking about crime at least
he talked about it when he was running
there's you have to vote for him you
have to is he doing anything about it no
no I mean I think in his case it's more
incompetence
um it was basically once once it was
clear Trump got the nomination he very
quickly started moving away from as I
said all the people who advised him to
help him get the nomination to Jared's
put in charge of
everything so so okay let's go back to
the team of putting the team together
who were you fully against who was okay
who was a good hire of the people he
chose and by the way that could include
the VP cuz I know the VP was who it was
supposed to be gingr it was Christie it
was it was chrisy gingr himself and one
other right that were possibilities of
being the VP who did he do where you're
like what are you doing and who did he
do where you're like okay that's a good
hire
um it was more it was mostly I'm trying
to think right now it was mostly lower
level people um I don't think there's oh
well I guess but it's not my field for
will baross I know I think he was
probably a could hire um Wilbert Ross
was 98 years old I know but it's not in
my area so I shouldn't even talk about
that I think he may have been sore half
the Senators by the way that's true just
um Betsy DeVos was great it turned out
she was very good and I think that's
about it for the cabinet oh and I I
liked Jeff sessions but who was the one
lonely voice in the woods saying don't
make him attorney
general and are you tough to please no
no it would have been so easy it would
be so easy put I mean for one thing I'd
keep sessions in the Senate um but if
you're going to put him someplace put
him someplace you know in Homeland and
then have co-ack if he's not head of
Homeland put him in charge of of
immigration um but I don't know I'd keep
I'd keep sessions in the Senate and the
argument that was made to me was oh he's
always wanted to be attorney general and
love Jeff Jeff sessions but I said this
isn't like um Make A Wish Foundation
you're president now this is really
important but no and and I don't think
sessions did anything wrong it was
horrible how how Trump humiliated him
but um I wouldn't have put him there I
would have kept him in the Senate and
look Trump ended up losing a senate seat
for us are you tough to please and what
I mean by tough to please is okay so for
example you know uh uh what president in
the last you know however many years who
has done a job where you're like okay
this guy came through and did his part
like who has been someone where you've
said that's my guy I'm sticking with him
he did great he came through he kept his
word da d d da who was the person that
well I'm I mean I'm with Reagan on the
point sorry I'm not one of these nut
Republicans who can only sight Reagan
drives me crazy but I think he was the
one who said with politicians if they're
80% with me and 20% against me that's
enough that's enough that's fine for me
and so I'd say that's true with um a a
lot of them I think you have to be kind
of I think it's hard to be a normal
person and run for president you have to
be a little bit of a of a narcissist or
something
um but I I'm I'm I'd say more than 80%
satisfied with Governor DeSantis you're
80% satisfied more than okay with
there's very little I would criticize
about DeSantis I mean the co response
were down to him and the president of of
of Sweden I had him on my podcast right
before the first debate and I and I said
um I considered it like debate prep and
I said okay now you're the absolutely
the best head and shoulders no one can
compare to you on immigration crime and
coid response so we're going to do a
little do a little test on this no
matter what I ask you you start to
answer and then turn it right back
around to immigration crime or your Co
response and on Co I said look nobody
nobody compares to you when you were
taking all the slings in the arrows so
unless the president of Sweden is
running in next year's presidential
election you are way ahead of the rest
of them on that this is with the sanas
so how do you think he's doing
today
um I I wish he had read in Trump We
Trust I gave him a copy I said but you
have to actually do it um you think he
read it I don't I don't know I think
he's I still I still don't think Trump
is going to be the nominee though I
wouldn't put money on it I've put many
stake bets on it that may be a mistake I
have a feeling I'm Jin going to be the
nominee and in what way yeah yeah the
well I wrote about this it's on my
subsag it was about two months ago
because I remembered this I looked back
and saw who was leading um who was the
um the polls for the pre Republicans
nominee for like 20 years it was never
the guy who turned out to be the nominee
a year before the election it's always
um name recognition so you know we can
go visit the Rudy Giuliani Presidential
Museum after this or the new Gingrich
Presidential Museum or the Fred Thompson
Presidential Museum or the Huckabee
Huckabee ly Dole ly Dole was neck and
neck with bushers litty Dole why because
she was the wife of the guy who had just
run president it's all name recognition
we've never had somebody with so much
name recognition as Donald
Trump name another human on the face of
the Earth who who's that recognizable
and everybody knows that name and
desandis I think put it well but very
briefly what he said is presidential
elections aren't decided by polls
they're decided by voters and look you
can have me back and laugh at me because
I could be totally wrong and I'm I'm a
little you're one you're one for one and
so I want to hear this CU I want to bet
I don't feel as confident as I did real
Qui you feel as confidence with the
santis as you did with Trump no but it's
not disantis no I don't feel as much
confidence saying Trump won't be the
nominee you want to put a steak dinner
on it I already have too many
or I'm going to bankrupt myself and and
then and and and is there if your reason
for saying that he won't is it because
of everything that they're doing right
now legally illegally in my mind to
completely destroy him because if you
think about it mentally politically
financially it's an allout assault it's
completely like if you don't see it I'm
saying as the public you're dumb is that
your reason for saying it or exactly the
opposite the Democrats know exactly what
they're doing and I wrote about this the
day of the again on ancter dos Subs
act.com the day of after the um Alvin
Bragg absurd indictment in New York
Trump was dead in the water before that
nobody showed up at his announcement
speech Fox cut away from it it was a
boore he was collapsing in the polls but
the smart Democrats I mean okay I'll
admit on msnb they genuinely hate him
yeah time but that Dove tales with the
smart Democrats like David Axelrod
sitting back and saying okay here's our
reelection plan for Joe Biden trick
Republicans into nominating Donald
Trump and man did Republicans fall for
it oh they're easy to roll and they keep
doing this because every time they do it
I mean this was the theme of my last
book resistance is futile I kept finding
myself at cocktail parties arguing with
New York Times reporters telling them
drop the Russia stuff it's stupid this
is what you should be attacking him for
there's loads to attack him for why are
you doing things that you force me to
defend him and that's what they do they
force people like me and I don't want to
defend the man to defend him by these
utterly preposterous indictments the
only one that's at all legit and it's
it's legit but should he go to prison
for it is the Florida Maraga one if if
somebody little word to the wise if if
you get a
subpoena from a DA's office or PR
Federal Prosecutor Office you have to
comply of course yeah of course so what
are you thinking what are you thinking
here what okay well here's my thing well
with that I'm thinking with it's
completely it's all Bs and I think you
nailed it actually and so the left
doesn't let a crisis ever go to waste
yes you always you know that right so
for instance with Co and they're
brilliant they're say what you want
about the left they are geniuses because
they do capitalize 70% of Voters didn't
vote on Election Day the last election
you know that right the the it I'm sorry
they didn't an election dat it was it
used to be the absentee ballots it used
to be 30% to 70% because of coid
everybody staying home it was 70 to 30
okay they all it was a coordinated
effort U Zuckerberg donated what 420
million they had antifa on the streets
they were you know suppressing the vote
suppressing uh like you mentioned
earlier too Twitter had how many FBI
agents there they had $3.5 million FBI
gave to stay there censor all the
stories all the Biden stuff so my
question to you is and people thought
that they cheated and what are you
concerned that they're going to
manufacture another crisis to keep you
know to do that same thing or is it are
the pieces of the game already set up
for them to
win if we if it if it's Trump It's Easy
Street for the Democrats I mean also you
have to remember they do they do control
the media of course of course and
whenever Republicans have some great
idea or conc obers are pushing on me and
and I say say why it won't work and they
say yeah but that's not fair because
that's not how the media treated
Democrats and I say as with January 6 um
but the media is being unfair to us if
you are so stupid not to know that the
media is farle and you're not going to
get any help from them you shouldn't be
running into the capital you are too
dumb to even remember to go to the
bathroom um so if it's they can mostly
sit back on Easy Street if if their
whole reelection plan for Biden is get
trick Republicans into renominating
Trump if it's not Trump okay and if
Biden if if Biden has to debate with Ron
DeSantis over what they're going to do
is my suspicion is they'll pretend we've
got a new variant I and and mind you
they test they tried testing it and
where people we were we were we were
just tired of it but I I I I just have a
feelingz do you genuinely think that's
going to be Biden Biden's going to make
it to this to the actual he's going to
be the guy I know who else would you do
you think because you know Nome I'm not
running I'm kind of running he's
debating the santis we don't we're still
baffled who do you think if it's not
going to be Biden who do you think is
going to be that that that sneak that
slippery snake that just comes in um and
by the way this may be one way the
Democrats um although they're conning
Republicans trying to get them to
renominate Trump they could Al be
conning too many of themselves that they
think oh yeah it's definitely going to
be Trump we don't have to worry about
anything keep we'll do weekend at Beres
this will be fine um if it turns out
that when voters go to vote they do not
vote for for Trump then they really are
going to be in so much trouble but I
think they have to I don't know that
much about like election law but I think
they have to decide Prett def fast
because there are state laws I believe
that prevent you from being on the
ballot if you're not nominated in time
and I think they have like another month
to make a decision so you think they're
doing all of this stuff to give Trump
momentum and help him out to be the
nominee and beat the santis I think the
Smart Ones are the dumb ones just hate
Trump and that's basically the entire
MSNBC staff so so they so you're saying
they are scared that the santis is going
to come and beat Biden that's what they
fear I think almost the Sanz is having a
hard time beating Nikki Haley the santis
is getting you know first one he had a
hard time with vivec he's getting other
people that are coming up because you
know the and by the way again I'd love
to hear that part the follow-up would be
uh uh you got the most popular president
of all time okay not you know Joe Biden
you know Tony Robin status type of
motivational speaker but the most
popular president of all time that we
have 81 million votes whatever the
number is right okay Trump on the other
side the most uh uh fanatical uh uh
supporters Republicans have had in how
long maybe since Reagan fanatical
fanatical I don't think George Bush had
fanatical I don't think senior had
fanatical that doesn't get you more
votes okay but it's fanatical that comes
down to the middle which is the
independent Libertarians it's really
four or five different yeah Republicans
to to win yours okay fair so but when it
comes down to it you're saying a
DeSantis who has a hard time with the
stage when you watch him he's not
necessarily one that's winning it if you
look at this right here this is not us
showing it this is you know the poll
showing from how close he was to Trump
and how separated it gets more and more
and more and you see Haley is not coming
up to the point where somebody called
him a bird brain you know Haley who who
called a bird brain somebody who may
recognize your friend called him a bird
brain maybe that's because she's a
threat now that she's coming up she's
getting too much her you've always hated
her so you actually agree that she is
bird brain or hey were you the one that
sent her the bir bird cage in the food
somebody sent her they said Donald
Trump's Camp send her a bird so you
think the Santa stands a shot at beating
Biden yeah on the I mean yes I'm worried
for the reasons you say
um okay he's not a showman on the debate
stage and this could be you know wishful
thinking but one thing I've noticed
about presidents is we tend to go back
and forth I mean it's like me going back
and forth on boyfriends the smart um
ugly one and the good-looking stupid one
and you just keep going back and forth
and back and forth and um who won who
who's won so far it's actually a very
good case study well what you ought to
do is have like two at the same time
I'll talk to you
make yes and let's
goast and I throughout the day I talk to
Bob but at
night
Jose the the workout friend tennis
pro and the voters similarly see seem to
go back and forth between um highly
articulate uh presidents and marbles in
their mouth president So Reagan
unbelievably articulate I mean it drove
Democrats crazy and know Hollywood
Hollywood okay then we get marbles in
his mouth George Bush won um then we get
Mr Smooth Bill Clinton and oh you melts
in your mouth um
literally you know it's it's really sexy
you say
that and then we go from there from
another marbles in your mouth Bush to oh
my gosh the most articulate President we
probably ever had Barack Obama to Trump
who has a vocabulary of about 50 words
what do you mean he has the best words
China CH disaster he knows the best
words and they're the strongest and what
would you say to the people strongest
words Since you're speaking of your love
life and multiple guys that you
sound almost like a scorn lover you
sound like you're you're someone that
was in love you guys are fighting and
literally cursing each other out in the
White House you guys have this text
message relationship you guys are so
close you literally nailed his election
very sexist very sexist it reminds me of
that I don't know if you've seen this
the Seinfeld episode where Elaine is
going crazy because every time she's
angry at a woman cat fight cat fight cat
fight
and not smart people um who want to
attack me always do I mean look I I
don't know if you guys were paying
attention to politics then but when
Chris Christy governor of New Jersey
took on the teachers
unions oh my gosh that was the most
beautiful thing to behold and the public
sector viral Clips with him on that and
the public sector unions are a huge huge
problem for this country and for state
after state after state so I was a huge
Chris Christie fan oh and by the way met
with him too um privately and hared him
for two hours about immigration is the
most important issue but no he decides
he's going to listen to The Wall Street
Journal and collapses um so then I
didn't like him but when I was
supporting Chris Christie because he you
got to admit even when you hate what
he's saying he is funny he is articulate
he is everything you're saying Dan
santis isn't he's a little awkward on
stage which I think is fine um I think
people will get over that and just look
at his record at least that's what I'm
hoping
um you don't sound convinced though you
you're not convinced you're hoping
you're not well it's a long time in
advance I generally don't like to make
predictions they made me on Politically
Incorrect real time real time sorry real
time they're still Politically Incorrect
but still so let's go to The Exchange
you guys had a month ago can you pull
this up Rob let's let's just show The
Exchange you guys had a month ago so
wasn't
exactly so if you want to you want to go
to truth first yeah so an kther the
washed up political pundit who predicted
my win in 2016 then went un unbearably
crazy with her commands and wanting to
be part of everything to the
constitution of all has gone hostile and
angry with every bit of her ner very
nervous energy like many others I just
don't want her around she wasn't worth
the trouble and part two he says page
two he says has an cter has has been an
cther is a stone cold loser and then you
respond if you want to zoom in here
Trump begged me to go to Bedminster this
week I said only if I could record a
substack with them but the gigantic
cat is too afraid of me so instead
he did this Pat there was no cat in
there and it all in capital letters all
in caps leave the cats alone so so what
happened here what happened here with
the small little public Feud you guys
had a friend of mine who um owns a
restaurant in New York where a lot of
journalists go uh went out he it was
written up in a newspaper and he had the
newspaper on the wall and I happened to
be at the restaurant that night so I was
in the art article so we got everybody
in the article to sign this blown up
article so he wanted to get among the
people who go there are trumps um none
of the one names you know but still in
the neighborhood and so he wanted to get
Trump to sign it so he goes with um
Trump's sister out to Bedminster uh and
and Trump is signing it and he sees my
name there and my friend calls me I'm
out in the Hamptons and he's desperately
calling me I have to talk to you I can't
put this in a text I got to call I got
to call okay he he said you know her you
know her you got to get her out to
Bedminster and he said he circled around
to me three different times he said I
you got to get her to Bedminster you got
to get her to Bedminster and I'm
thinking well I don't want to hurt the
restaurant tour's feelings but there's
no effing way I'm going to Bedminster
and then as soon as I hang I I said I'll
think about it but you know and probably
not then I hang up and think oh my gosh
I have a substack and so I text him back
and say no I won't go to to Bedminster
but I want him to do a subsec video with
me which I do all the time about once a
week and I have big important people and
not as big as you but pretty big
um um and I know he's not going to do it
so first he comes back and says oh he
doesn't do zoom and then I'm saying okay
I'll come out there and I'm talking to
all my techie friends saying I need
every one of you wearing a GoPro because
I'm going to go out there and he's going
to say no I won't be interviewed he
wouldn't do it on camera I knew he
wouldn't um so all I get back is oh um
yes maybe we'll set it up you know
people are going back to Florida now
this was a month ago nobody's back in
Florida in in SE August he's not going
back to Florida so some of my journalist
friends said so is this happening is
this happening are you going and before
this even happened I texted the exact
same thing to him and I said it's not
happening he's a gigantic um he's
too scared of me he won't do it and then
you know I'm just going about my day a
few days later and I start getting all
these emails why is Trump attacking you
out of the blue on Truth social well
this is his chicken way of saying so how
how much after the exchange did this
attack on on uh truth come out oh it
happened like two days after they were
giving me BS excuses about when we're
going to do the subst so why do you
think he wanted to meet with you in
bedminister what do you think his
outcome was or was take a picture with
me to to and put it up on Truth social
and say look who's supporting me again
oh wow but he wouldn't do that oh he
totally would you know why I don't think
he would do that you know why I don't
think he would do that because within
seconds you would deny it okay but I
denied I explained what happened with
that attack he doesn't care no no but it
would it would be a very bad look for
him to do that uh uh uh for example
little bwow post a picture like six
years ago I don't know if you know this
guy he's a big time he was he was a big
rapper 20 years ago the oh him so he
posts a picture that hey Jet flying you
know stuff like this and then a guy
responds back and says he's not jet
flying he was on a commercial airplane
what was this all about it was the most
embarrassing thing I don't know if you
remember this or not when this took
place K so to for Trump to post a
picture of you to say who's supporting
me within seconds you would trash that I
don't know has a much bigger megaphone
no I don't he's the ex president no he
no but but but are you kidding me
mainstream media hates him they would
you would be Center State story invited
to every single CNN MSNBC to trash him
you would get that in I don't think that
would be they will only invite people on
I mean isn't that isn't that curious
that they haven't invited me on to trash
him why because I trash him for not
keeping his promis this is how much they
want open borders and they want to
destroy this country if you attack him
from the right as I'm doing yeah oh no
it's you're Kryptonite to the networks
only if you come on and say we almost
lost our
democracy so your biggest issue with
Trump essentially is he's not trumpy
enough he didn't keep his promises you
you nailed the nail on the head you're
not attacking him from the left everyone
else is you're attacking him from the
right and your biggest critique of him
is straight up the open borders
immigration not building the wall policy
right yes and you live in you know
you're as conservative and as right
leaning as you are you spend your time
in with the East Coast Elite you're in
you're in La San Francisco what have you
and you're New York here's my question
New York we see what's going on with
Eric Adams we' seen what the governor
Kathy hul is saying when are New Yorkers
going to wake up and realize all right
maybe this Sanctuary City thing ain't
what the cat pajamas is all about what
do you say they're waking up and God
bless Governor D santis he started it he
said it first and then that Martha's
Vineyard thing is what set it off and I
mean Abbott has more illegal aliens it's
basically it's an open border this is
why we need a wall um and I think more
and more Americans are seeing this is
the problem with not having a wall and I
just want to point out anyone who talks
about border security and does not say
we need a wall is a liar
nothing will work but a wall and by the
way I don't know if you saw today Joe
Biden is saying he's going to start
building a wall and blow off
environmental regulations proving my
that would be the Biden nothing works
but a wall and the only one who I think
is trustworthy enough
um I mean VC I was just going to ask you
I love v he's I I hate to say this I I
don't trust him as far as I can throw
him his best ideas are all coming from D
santis but oh my gosh that that kid is
articulate um so the only one I really
trust to build a wall is is D santis so
not Trump so of all the people you're
saying that Trump wouldn't be the most
likely person to four years he had a
republican house and a senate no he does
not give two and I'm about to
defend Trump right now don't you think
he actually wanted to build a wall no he
why would he lie about the wall they
they got him the presidency so you don't
think he actually generally in his bone
wants to build the wall genuinely I
don't know something that you easily
could have done at any point for let's
I'll just I'll even give you year two or
three and four and by the way he didn't
need Congress but if you have it in your
head that you need Congress you have a
republican house and a Republican Senate
and what did he do he passed Paul Ryan's
tax cuts well he wanted to go to
healthcare first uh so and and what do
you what do you say to like yeah he did
a lot on Healthcare didn't he yeah ex
obviously didn't and what do you say
about uh because VC's attitude uh he was
interviewed well he just stopped
somebody he was doing Grassroots going
to like coffee shops and somebody's like
how are you going to fix the Border he
said I would deploy our military and
literally put them at the southern
border are you are you are you Santa
said that first and he said it better
and I wish I could just make him our
president um he wears high heel boots
you can't give him RZ though an I think
he may not need it well really how do
you not need Charisma and personality
and Riz to be the president other than
Joe Biden W Bush George W bush that's
that that's a different social media and
you know how this works these days it's
Showmanship It's Entertainment politics
pre-2000 wasn't Showmanship how may
you're right social media I'm right on
this one you might I might be losing a
lot of steak bets but I I just think
that before people vote what they do is
they look at the candidates there's
generally I I'm trying to remember do
they have a debate in every state at
least the early States before each prime
primary or caucus they definitely have
one in Iowa they will have one in New
Hampshire they will have one in South
Carolina and I mean I always find it
weird when how many people there are who
don't care about politics at all they
know as much about politics as I know
about football zero um but before
they're going to vote they know a
presidential election is important
they're civic-minded they're just you
know I don't know they have lives um and
before that that primary comes they look
up the candidates and that's why we
didn't have President Fred
Thompson yeah and oh and as for Haley
there was one thing I was going to say
about why I think she's going up in the
polls there was one thing that I will I
will admit I so far I've been I've been
wrong about because every four years my
entire life at some point during the
Republican Presidential um um nomination
process or a primary process the black
Republican is pulling at number one or
number two and I mean many of them I've
actually genuinely liked like Herman
Kane and his 999 I liked Allen Keys um
lots of them but it's just so pathetic
that Republicans are so desperate not to
be called racist oh I like Colin Powell
for president oh good for you um and so
I predicted that at some point Tim Scott
yes there it is there now Tim Scott
would be pulling first or second at some
point first or second so far I have been
wrong but now I think Haley's taking
taking the
no I'm for a woman you can't call me
sexist yeah because I think she's been a
absolute disaster in the debates so
you're saying it's all just Optics or
there actually Steve Schmidt your old
buddy who was McCain's uh campaign
manager actually was like oh I didn't
realize how racist the Republican Party
really yeah yeah so what are you exactly
saying about the black nominees and the
racism Republican party no nobody's
racist nobody um well actually there's a
lot of anti-white word
racism the number of white people who
are
racist you we couldn't fill up this
room so no but Republicans are so I mean
your average Republican obviously I'm
not are so afraid of the mainstream
media calling them racist no let's prove
them wrong let's prove them wrong it's
the weirdest thing I don't know white
people have a suicidal
Gene white guilt is what it's called you
brought something up and there's
something to be said you know the
national polls are National poll
and then we go to New Hampshire then we
go to Iowa and people still don't
understand even though it's been
explained at length that Iowa is not an
election it's a it's an elimination
caucus it goes like this like this like
this like this and so all the national
polls do this because they have to sell
ads and have something to say you know
all the people on TV that you know don't
make jobs they make noise so you've got
the national polls saying oh what about
this what about this that's why Fred
Thompson was up after he goes on Johnny
Carson and he talks about that I
remember that
and that's why you know Mike Huckabee
Huck aoom the headline was on um uh
drudge in the early days of drudge when
everybody was like is this really a
newspaper what's going on how is he
influencing us and then you go down to
the the micr Pooles so the the question
is Within These microp Pooles they
always surprise everybody so do you
think and I'm kind of circling back that
in New Hampshire and Iowa and South
Carolina the first three that matters
because then a bunch of pack Money
Follows you almost like like the vortex
right
um that they're going to find a way
basically to keep Trump off the ballot
cuz that's the only way he loses those
primaries in in what 110 days oh I don't
think
so you think do you think that he can
lose on the ballot and
lose
yes wow
that's wow that's that's surprising
because you look at the you look I'm not
saying it'll happen I'm not confident
but um
I think it can happen
how
it's I I just think people start paying
attention and I think the real Trump
cultists the ones um who say we don't
care what he does we don't care we don't
care if he doesn't build a wall we don't
care if he gives amnesty to dreamers I
think the number of Republicans who
think that is not is not that big I
think there is that that cult and that
you think that that's 40% of
Republicans I'm thinking it's more like
10% and they'll come along who don't
care who don't care about any of the
issues it's just it's a cult of
personality and and you see them on
Twitter of the Republicans right of
Republicans because it's I I don't know
maybe Republicans are dumber than I
thought well the math is is sort of
proving you wrong I mean if you look at
the his approval ratings within the
Republican party I mean it's no longer
the Republicans if you don't agree with
Donald Trump you are now officially a
rhino you're a rhino I don't know what
the hell you're stegosaurus or at this
point it's magga or nothing or nothing I
am worried that that crowd the
personality personality C may be may be
bigger than I think
um but I I just think most of those
people when they're when they are asked
because it's always been a popularity
contest the year before there's no
reason to think this year is different
um
I think when they say Trump what they
mean is screw you media I hate you
Democrats I hate Biden I hate what's
going on and the first name they can
think of I mean ask me to name a
football player um what's his name Tom
Brady okay I'm out now Taylor Swift
she's she's the biggest football player
in the world now I I got no more names
for you so I think a lot of people are
like that that um I mean the the not
caring about politics is utterly foreign
to me but you do meet such people and
when they say Trump I think it means
something different and and to that
extent I agree with with Mah um that I
love Trump supporters I mean even when I
hated him when he was president and you
know you'd see these huge Trump Flags I
might would always warm my heart the big
signs I thought oh I'm sure I would like
these people because I think they like
him because of all that wall stuff
because of how he was going to put us
first how he was going to bring jobs
back how he was going to you know bring
strike better trade deals well didn't do
any of that but he moved the embassy
what do you think now voter now those
people I think we win back the
percentage of the ones where they
literally wouldn't care if you were
governing exactly like Biden they're
just slobbering over Trump Trump trump
Trump trump yeah we're not going to win
them back and and you said you travel a
lot right I assume in 2015 2016 when you
nailed the TR the Trump thing you had
the Maga Republicans taking pictures
with you shaking your giving you hugs
when you travel now I assume the the
Liberals still hate you no doubt what's
the Republican Maga people say to you
when they see you well
it it's probably not
representative
um because of where the places I'm going
to end
up but actually after the 20 I don't
know if it was after 2020 or it was
after January 6 I've had so many
Republicans come up to me and say I
hated you when you were attacking Trump
during the presidency and now I see you
were right so that's all I've gotten
from Republicans now I don't think
that's representative I haven't gone to
I don't I don't know where these TR
Trump cultist live I mean I when I saw
January 6 I think I tweeted this um I
thought to myself I've been wondering
who still supports this this guy okay
there they are and they're not they're
not exactly Masters of the Universe the
shaman the shaman exactly those are the
people so I'm not in a place where I I
want to believe you I want to believe
you but but the the numbers don't
support what you're saying so it makes
you look bitter and it makes you look
angry and it makes you look that no one
can please you that I trust me like
you're somebody that I watched over the
years even until today when you talk
there's like you know in finance there's
a guy that they think he's cuckoo his
name is Michael buy Michael bur is the
guy from the movie Big Short he's the
guy that said the Market's going to
collapse he's out of his mind he's crazy
he's not he just had a $1.6 billion bet
against the S&P 500 6 weeks ago they're
like what so he took $1.6 billion of his
client's money and he shorted the S&P
500 what's this guy thinking n he
doesn't know what he's talking about
he's an idiot he's this he's that I want
to know what he has to say right okay
you are a Michael bur of politics cuz
you said Trump's going to win and he did
now Michael bur's not 100% right he's
not always going to get it right
impossible right cuz it's speculation
there's a lot of things that came same
with you so to be fair to you you're not
going to be 100% right this is not a
world that you can be 100% right but a
part of me is listening to you and
saying okay is she upset with maybe you
know you wanted something from him he
didn't give it to you that's option
number one okay two yeah a wall yeah
okay cool number two is she upset that
maybe he said he was going to do what he
was going to do and he didn't okay fair
you're right the wall all this other
stuff great yeah he had you had house
you know you had Congress you had Senate
all fair is she upset that you know uh
maybe they had a feud and something went
there maybe about the wall what is she
what is she upset about now your
confence I don't think I could be
clearer about this no I I I I am with
you I'm I'm you've been very clear today
to understand where you stand uh with
this year but the voter is still saying
we want this guy back in on the
Republican side than anybody
and it ain't even close we were at both
GOP debates not going to lie to you was
that the first one Milwaukee exciting
second one we fell asleep half the
audience was asleep it was boring first
one Vic showed up second one Nikki Haley
showed up both the santis was number two
so he can't pull off the first not in
the polls I know not in the polls but
you know when you watch him he's just
the safe guy he gives the safe answers
you know the first one he kind of leaned
on Christie to go after you know Vic and
to go after Trump but he didn't go after
Trump but on the second one his campaign
guys came back and said if you're really
going for it you got to go after Trump
so then he went after Trump and then in
the conversation with Sean Hannity I
think we should do more of these I would
love to do one-onone if we're doing one
with Nome I'd love to do one with Trump
okay yeah great you know but then the
audience and voters are like still the
same no movement there is nothing that's
exciting it's almost like a person you
like that you want to see flourish right
but they can't win the people over so
what do you do then so let's let's just
kind of go in this scenario with you
let's say it is Trump okay and let's say
it's against Biden maybe Kamala long
shot Nome I don't think Nome could
because if Nome did they're GNA say look
the white men fired a black women's job
and that story line on the Republicans
going to be phenomenal they're not going
to let Nome even though it should be
Nome they're just not going to let it
happen here it'll happen 2028 it's
catastrophic for Democrats if he takes
it over Cala so let's say this Biden
Trump what are you going to do
who you going to support are you going
to sit this one out are you going to
vote for Joe Jorgenson are you going to
be like I'm going to go libertarian
independent are you GNA wait for RFK to
do something what is cter gonna
do um I'm I'm I am worried that that it
could be Trump but one prediction I'm
very confident of is if it is Trump he's
gonna lose in fact it'll probably be a
1964 style landslide so it'll be a slow
motion airplane crash for me um and I
mean as you'll see from my substack I
don't I don't write that much about
obviously as we're heading into an
election year I'm writing a lot more
about politics but it's more about
specific things like immigration like
crime um like like anti-white racism and
and the affirmative action cases um so I
figure and there are people who who do
that and I find them very interesting um
if it if it's Trump I'm I'm not paying
attention I I don't want to watch the
plane crash and the one satisfaction I
will have is and it's not satisfaction
I've done everything I can um to save
this country from from high crimes and
misdemeanors through even defending
Trump to some extent and resistance is
futile by attacking the media and
writing in Trump We Trust um I've done
everything I can
do it's over at that point point and I
don't wouldn't say it's satisfaction but
the people who are going to suffer the
most are the ones in the Trump cult are
the 10,000 people or however many
thousand ran into that capital building
I'm still going to have a great life in
fact my my pool boy going to be a lot
cheaper and you know who's going to
really suffer those people in the cult
who just don't care and won't look at
the wall and won't look at the issues
and won't look at the fact that we're
becoming a third world country and
they're going to be pushed aside they'll
be living up in the Shacks like in
Venezuela my life is fine in Brazil in
Venezuela I'm going to do great and I'm
doing everything I can to say the save
the lives of people who apparently hate
me what if you're
wrong I just told you what my life is
going to be life like if I'm wrong pool
you know cleaner is going to be cheaper
all that stuff but what if you're wrong
boy which part of that isong but but no
no what I mean is okay so for I really
try to think on why some of the things
didn't get done on first term okay you
know how sometimes a first-term
president's biggest fear is what to be a
one-term president it's a fear it was is
but no it was pre Co he would have been
a two no he would not have he would the
economy was good there was no Wars Isis
was gone what's the one demographic he
lost compared to 2016 anyone know anyone
know what's the one demographic he lost
the women nope white men and it was in
mostly the industrial Midwest the states
he lost that is not because of Co they
weren't living in New York City he
gained a bunch of other things you're
you're picking one thing he lost out of
all the other things he won but here's
where I'm going with well he lost the
election what he did kind of important
you got to win election but losing the
election was a Black Swan I mean you're
smart enough to know wasn't like a it
wasn't I knew he was going to lose the
election that one I would have I would
have bet you a million bucks on that in
fact I did make bets on that that's why
I only make stake bets now because
people never pay monetary bets and I
made a lot of bets on that of course he
was going to lose the one thing I
underestimated with or without Co with
or without of course of course based on
what premise yeah I want to know this
based on what premise both Democrats and
Republicans all say he would have won if
I warned him about this in columns I
think before he was president maybe
right when he became president think
back to the one-term president is it
this last time yeah last time
Republicans had a one-term President
George W bush and why was that one time
at the Republican National Convention he
said read my lips no new taxes and the
media tricked him into raising taxes and
his voters said you betrayed us you made
a promise and you lied he didn't say it
at every single rally every single day
when everything your entire campaign is
I'm going to build the wall and you
don't build the wall of course he was
going to lose re-election so the one
thing I underestimated was um did not
think he was that stupid he is that
stupid respectfully sound bitter now and
and and the reason why respectfully I
wanted a wall like the rest totally get
it oh totally get it I did too I'm not
I'm not sitting here saying I didn't
want the wall I still want the wall uh
I'm a guy that left Iran I lived in Iran
10 years two years in a refugee camp
trust me I wanted that as well but in my
mind I'm I don't sit there and agree
with a lot of things he did I'm just
sitting there saying what happened to
America during his term and I think he
would have gotten reelected was it not
for coid but let me go back to the
question here so what if what if let's
do the what if what if in his mind
what if in his mind you know him better
than I do you communicated with him
you've been on calls with him you've
been in meetings with him you've had
more interaction with him than I have
mine is pure speculation is what I'm
doing but I'm a person that's body
language I'm watching frustrations of
people that's the world I'm in the last
20-some years what if in his mind he's
saying you know uh uh everything that
you know such and such things I'm going
to do second terms these things I'm
going to do first terms on the second
term I don't give a if I get
reelected or not I'm done so you like me
you don't like me I'm going to get all
of this stuff done in second term first
term let's make sure we get the economy
to be scored away let's make sure we get
the job and unemployment to be good for
certain communities let's make sure we
fix certain things with you know Tel
Aviv is you know you Jerusalem let's do
Isis let's doam salmani let's do some of
these things and then second term we'll
do the wall we'll do this we'll do that
what if that was part of a strategy what
if that's not saying it's the right
strategy what if that was part of a
strategy well a he should have told us
that during the campaign this I'm not
going to build the wall first term no
when I said said I'm going to start day
one when I said I'm deporting dreamers
day one no what I meant was day one of
my second term so a don't lie to us when
you're campaigning and getting our votes
B you sound like a a battered woman
making excuses well maybe he won't hit
me next time it's been four years he's
been beating the crap out of you he had
four years Patrick four years two with a
republican Congress oh but I know he he
could have not hit me but maybe he was
thinking he was waiting for our golden
annivers to stop hitting me he was just
waiting for that perfect time no he had
four years he didn't build it I don't
know what other proof you could possibly
want but but did didn't they I mean they
started they did start building he did
nothing for two years there was Zero
building of the wall during Trump and in
the end he bought bro built according to
his own Homeland Security about 50 miles
50 miles across a 2,000 mile border and
and how much of all that with well Pat
said the goals and this and that I I do
disagree I think Trump would have won
100% if there wasn't Co but what about
everything that was happening during
that four years Russia collusion racist
it was just over and over and over how
can you even focus at at one thing when
every like they were trying to get him
out since day one well if he can't focus
he shouldn't be president and it was the
same way during the campaign you think
they were you know it was all it was all
um you know Wine and Roses during the
campaign it was one thing after another
the Mexican judge the Mexican rapist um
every little thing he said they would
leap on it was headline news he was Bozo
the McCain thing um how about Access
Hollywood they wait until 11 days before
the election and yet he still managed to
give those rally speeches saying I'm
going to build the wall day one he could
stay really focused when he was horn
swgl us but then when he has all the
power in the world he's president of the
United States he can hire whever he
wants to he can get the wall built day
one like you said in Anor babies day one
and he totally could have done that he
kept claiming hey let's take Anor babies
Anor babies as I'm sure you all know
from my magnificent book adios America
um anchor babies are an invention of one
Justice on the Supreme Court Justice
Brennan wrote it's not even part of the
holding it's dictat as we lawyers say
it's in a footnote that that anyone born
in the United States even to an illegal
an absurd concept is a United States
Citizen and you know I I always thought
huh that's odd why would the drafters of
the 14th Amendment have thought okay
everybody now in case a Mexican runs
across the border at eight months
pregnant we've got to make sure that
child is a citizen and everyone's saying
oh my gosh that isn't already in the
Constitution I mean it makes no sense so
I look it up I find out it's just from
this one case Justice Brennan drops it
no Congress has ever passed a law saying
the children of illegal aliens are
citizens no court has ever ruled that it
is just a like a policy that's followed
in fact after the 14th Amendment you
know who wasn't a United States citizen
the children of n of of of American
Indians born on us soil were not US
citizens because they were subject to
the Tribal Law it
is famous federal judges who don't agree
with me on anything Richard Posner most
cited federal judge 7th circuit he used
to say would you end this nonsense and
this was 30 years ago he was begging
Congress to clarify that the 14th
Amendment does not apply to Anor babies
okay having given you that history um
what would a president do about it well
i' I'd push Congress to pass a law but
in the
interim sign an executive order weirdly
in this one case you're not overturning
a law you're not overturning a court
case because haha there is no law there
is no court case um and he kept saying
he was going to do it he said it during
the campaign over and over and over
again you know when the next and almost
last time he said it was right before
the midterm elections it would have
taken him less time to sign his name
than to put out a press release saying
he was going to issue so why do you
think he didn't do it he doesn't give a
crap about what about anything he said
about immigration and the border and
anger babies he doesn't care he wants to
it's All The Apprentice to him he wants
to be beloved he wants to get be able to
sell stuff he wants the crowd's cheering
for him so as long as he says it I mean
he's all he's as dumb as the media is
they both seem to think that once the
words come out of his mouth it's as if
he's done it so he gets attacked as if
he's done it he feels like oh well
that's done I said I'm going to do it so
then you think you think the the big
poll lead that he has right now on
everybody else all those guys that
support him are
you're saying no I'm saying he's he's
he's what are they happy about think
what they're happy about like why are
they doing it again I don't know I could
be wrong I could be wrong I think I
think a lot of it is hatred for his
enemies and I understand that I mean
that's why I think a lot of us really
liked Sarah Palin who had a lot of flaws
and yet it's the enemies of my enemies
and oh my gosh are the enemies of Donald
Trump easy to hit and have you ever been
have you ever been married before or no
did you ever get close to getting
married
mhm what so so this is getting a little
personal but I'm going to I'm going to
ask a different and I'm going to ask you
for and by the way again I think this is
sexist oh the the Christy point when I
was for Christie yeah they'd all say oh
chubby chasy chubby chubby chaser I
didn't even know what that meant it's
like girls like fat guys to have sex
with um no this isn't a sexual thing I
want a wall my social life is fine no
that's not what I'm asking but but the
but the part I'm asking is uh when when
you're saying this is getting kind of
personal it's a question you don't have
to answer it you can simply say I don't
want to talk about it I'm totally okay
with that no I I feel uh you know
certain people are very hard to please
I'm not hard to please well let me let
me make my point so for example I've had
relationships where the craziest thing
I've ever he heard he runs on building a
wall four years he doesn't build a wall
oh you demand everything no but I I
can't please this woman are you mad no
I'm not I'm not mad I'm just watching
you listen to question so so for me for
me I feel like there are certain people
that you have to be very careful because
they're either super gunko about you and
the Rel like I've dated girls where
relationship was it was unfreaking
believably high peak the peak was so
high it doesn't make any sense right on
how high the peak was like this is going
to be freaking insane but dude talk
about the low the low was
painful you needed 15 therapists and
friends and sponsored by tequila and
vodka and whiskey to be able to tolerate
the shitty low you would go through with
this girl I'm like I can't tolerate this
and I've been around the block you
know I'm like you when you're were
talking at first I wanted this
girl so you know I wasn't the innocent
one eventually I'm like dude I'm
shutting it down this is it I'm I'm I
want to build a family I want to have a
different kind of a life and I went I
never thought I was going to get married
I thought I was going to stay single for
the rest of my life cuz that was no one
was going to make me happy and then I
sat there and I said is it going to be a
100% of everything across the board and
then that's it is it going to be like I
they have to give me that's it and then
I'm not going to look at all the other
stuff you're you're clinging on one
thing that I'm also not happy about I
wanted to border I'm also not happy
about that by the way a lot of the
things he ran on he should have done all
of that stuff he has to answer that
question a person like you has to give
that question to a moderator in the in
the what do you call it in the
presidential election that's coming up
someone has to pose that question I want
to know what his answer is going to be
I'd like to see some other people that
are his friends ask questions like that
a hanity and others to actually ask
those questions because I want to know
but at the same time I don't know if any
presidential candidate is going to be
able to please an cther for8 years I
don't think that's possible because I
think that person is going to have to do
everything you want them to do to to win
your favor and it is so attractive to
get your uh uh get your support
because during the election there was
certain people that are superstars that
played a role of trump winning in 2016 I
think you're one of them I think kellyan
Comm was one of them she didn't support
him until two months before the election
she was Cruz but but I but I thought she
played her role in those two months I
think she crush the show up and defend
him for Access Hollywood and did I I
understand again I'm not putting you
guys against each other on who's more
than the other one you're you your
method of going out there and going
after the enemy you're you're Fearless
you're you scare the crap out of the
enemy you're not a person that people
sit there and like you you make people
on the other side Shake y okay so you
played a role she played a role other
people played a role okay but then we
come to now you're clinging on one thing
okay it's more than one thing then then
unpack it if you're saying it's more
than one thing if you're saying it's
it's more than just a border what okay a
couple things the reason I mentioned
kellyanne isn't don't pull this oh
Seinfeld cat fight cat fight isn't to
say no I was but I was for Trump a few
weeks after he announced and what I have
noticed you were the first to make it
clear everybody knows that and and did
you guys know this guy in 2015 because I
want confirmation on this point Adam you
did okay you're going to answer this no
Tom did yeah a lot of
us um who supported every single person
I know who supported Trump in 2015 and
everyone hated us for it um but a lot of
my friends did I mean after La you see
what the problem is before a lot of the
rest of the country I don't know one
person who supported Donald Trump in
2015 who supports him now who isn't
betrayed the the people who support him
now are the Johnny come lat Le who
absolutely opposed him they were for crw
they were for Rubio they didn't care
about anything that Trump was running on
and then oh screw it he's the nominee
let's see if we can get tax cuts out of
him they think it's magic that he won
because they never understood why he won
because they never understand and it's
not just one issue it's the whether our
country continues to exist is the issue
and as for your ex-girlfriend um you
needed therapy and tequila and and um
low was low and it would go on and on
now I understand why now I know
understand why you're willing to put up
with Donald Trump because I hit that and
I'm out the door yeah that sounds good
when you're saying that it's a good
oneliner on what you're saying but you
still sound bitter and frustrated look
what happened with a guy Nam tror just
an insult it's no it is you you're not
getting me this is like being called a
racist all day no it's not I'm not
that's not an argument I keep making
arguments and you keep saying you sound
bitter you got to come up with something
other than you sound better well you do
though you do so so do you know what
happened with Trevor bow do you know
this guy Nam Trevor bow okay so Tom did
you see what happened with Trevor bow
yesterday with wait a second I didn't
get an answer did he support Trump in
2015 not 2016 whether it's him or him or
him I'll will say this you you said
something actually very shocking that we
we should address you're saying you
don't know one person who supported
Trump in 2015 2016 that is still with
him today I'm in my circle yeah
in that's the whole difference Circle
how big is your circle what difference
does it make what are you going to say
an has a big circle it's not a small
circle she she's got contacts from
everywhere nobody's denying we know who
an we know who an cter is okay so let's
say it's a couple hundred let's say it's
a couple thousand let's say it's 10,
okay even publicly I can't think of
anyone I I know so many people that were
with him in 2016 that are unanimously
still with him today and don't believe
me don't believe me I said 2015 15 16
what's the difference it's a huge
difference what do you mean when he was
we supported him before the issues and
what he was saying you guys wanted Jeb
you would have been perfectly happy with
Jeb I'm saying the people he governed
like that voted for him no that's not
what I do you understand what I said I I
there's a reason that that I'm saying
2015 and not 2016 obviously people who
supported him in who else would it be
the people who voted him against him in
2016 what you're asking about is in 2015
when he declared and we still had crw
Jeb Rubio and the cast of thousands
right um and some of them hadn't even
fully declared yet right they the the
gold rush5 Fox 100% against him Murdoch
against himal against him did you
support when he declared in 2015 and
where you had this SL this slate and to
your point about name recognition
everybody thought that Jeb was going to
roll and at at uh thanksgiv 40 million
day one y yep yep at Thanksgiving 2015
all the money in the packs was behind
youb pledge not not donated but pledge
he he had it all so you're saying were
you behind Trump 2015 I'll say I wasn't
I was beginning of 16 soon as I saw him
picking people off soon as I saw what he
was able to do I said that cat that cat
is going to keep picking these people
off and so could could I say I was I was
early 16 but I see what you're mean it's
like when he declared were you with him
and saying this is my guy or not just
June 15th I'm giving you six months to
come around he kept talking about
immigration and I would add that ever
you think he's a good debater because
and I looked this up and wrote about
this recently on suback 2 it's easy to
forget because he did kind of change the
whole campaign sort of change the
landscape Republicans are afraid to say
some of the stuff they used to say
everyone on that debate stage with him
was open borders and they were all
attacking him when he came out for the
Muslim ban um Paul Ryan the rest of them
that's not who we are so he was being
attacked specifically the same way Dan
santis does the right thing on Co and
he's being attacked attacked attacked
attacked and he stands strong Trump was
standing strong all the rest of the were
attacking him that's the 215 landscape
for you those of you who didn't support
him in 2015 don't give a crap about
immigration you wanted tax cuts so
congratulations you got your tax cuts
but those of us who supported him for
the issues he ran on that set him apart
from every other candidate um say he
failed you're talking about the early
adopters well cuz six months you have
well and and take somebody like me cuz
I'm the I'm the average Joe military
veteran you know family legal immigrants
brother and sister uh military veterans
as well I could honestly have cared less
about Trump you know you fired all that
I never I could never care less the
personality when he was on stage when he
started going at people then I started
becoming more attractive because I'm
like okay he's he's funny he's witty I'm
a comedian myself but then I think once
seeing what they did with you know the
collusion the Russia and that he rised
and and I got into it with Steve Schmidt
big time where I was like cuz he's just
Lincoln project it's all Bs I go this
guy sacrificed everything winningly or
not winningly pulled back the curtain
and let us all see what they were doing
so it's like almost like we I we want
him and again I'm saying for us because
these are the people that you guys were
talking about it's almost we have to
because it's not fair what they did and
we want him to go again the Isis he
destroyed to me he tried with the with
the wall they wouldn't let him because
of you know racism he's racist racist
Mexicans all that stuff I'm that average
person that's like I'm sticking with the
guy that I I went for for the first time
and I want to see him try to accomplish
all those things the second time because
from the beginning it wasn't fair I'm
that average person that was with him
from 2015 cuz once I started seeing him
I was like it's Trump I'm from New York
you're from New York right and I wanted
that guy to win so it's like I'm that
average person that's still sticking
with him to this day it's weird I'm that
guy I'm that guy that you guys are keep
talking about cuz I'm like everything
they're they're cheating they're
actively cheating right now in New York
this case the judg is smiling and
laughing in the camera camera it's all
political it's all to destroy the guy I
get what you're saying and trust me I'm
100% proall I'm 100% Pro military I want
the those all the soldiers that are just
hanging out here and they're not
deployed anywhere put them on the border
put them I want armed people at the
border to to secure us and I mean and I
feel you that in that sense that they
did fail but all the other stuff we
can't deny all the other stuff that he
did he did a lot I will tell you this we
I would like to pursue that one um I I
mean yes I loved his judges but was all
the federal Society picking them because
L luckily Jared Kushner didn't care
about Judges so I think I don't think
you give them a lot of credit for the
judges because any Republican these are
the ones the federal Society was sending
up and that's who the Republican or
republican president's listen to they
happen to get it right this time
Federalist Society has gotten better too
so other than I I'm excluding that what
did he do that you like that Jeb Bush
wouldn't have done um well
I'll answer that where we are right now
today look just look at America compare
that to let's say 2017 it's not compared
to a Democrat that's easy no no no no no
no not Dem well that's easy but what I'm
saying is though that's the America that
I want to live in I want to I want to
feel safe I want the economy to be
booming and then all of a sudden and
this this virus comes out of a lab that
we own from a country that he's holding
accountable cuz mind you the the the
main The Establishment love China they
love that relationship with Trey and
everything Trump came in and said no no
no you guys are going to pay for your
and then all of a sudden on
election year this virus just comes out
shuts down the whole world mail and
ballots it's almost like it was a plan
but that that's my point it's it's I
felt way better I I could have cared
less the racism and all that I was like
yeah yeah yeah I didn't believe any of
that but now if you look at what's
happening like it's a no-brainer to to
want that guy to be to be running well
one of the things besides Co that was
very big in 2020 and you say and this
reminds me that you you want to feel
safe and boy we don't feel safe now
especially New York and la oh God Philly
all these places San Francisco I mean if
you're a city person like I am where
where do you go anyway um and that was
the George Floyd May 25th 2020 change
the world we suddenly we have to release
all the criminals among other things um
one place you would have been safe in
2020 was in Florida thank you Rhonda is
passing law after law where you can
shoot looters anti- rting laws I mean
there were specific actions he took that
made that meant there were no riots and
no police stations were burnt down and
you did not have police being assaulted
what did the commanderin-chief do what
did Trump do he sent out Tweets in all
caps Law and Order point one point two
you know what he said in the first
debate with with with Joe Biden and this
is after a year of them burning BLM
antifa burning down police stations
ripping down statues I mean Anarchy like
I've never seen in this country before
when that police station went down in
Minneapolis I was watching TV crying it
was so horrible they talk about January
6 let's talk about that at the first
debate what did Donald Trump say to Joe
Biden you called them super Predators
I'm releasing people from prison how
about the first step act thank you Jared
he's releasing criminals you want to
feel safe Donald Trump ain't your
guy okay so let's go back to Florida you
said the uh uh what what Ron did during
this time for Florida that's why we
moved here by the way yeah we're here
because of the Santa so you know here's
where you're about to be spooked we like
both where did you come from uh I lived
in La for 20 some years okay uh lived in
the I was in the Army for 3 years 2 and
A2 years I was in Dallas for 5 years
Plano and then we move moved here we
kind of wanted The Best of Both Worlds
if Texas and uh California had a baby I
think it's Florida and then Ron crushed
it the challenge for me was I think Ron
with his book launch campaign marketing
timing messaging selling uh to me he was
playing defense thinking Trump's not
going to be there by the end and his
strategy and Nome strategy was Biden's
not going to be there at the end Trump's
not going to be there at the end it's
going to be you and I that was the dream
matchup Lakers against the Celtics
the two young are going to come and
change politics instead of0 80y olds now
it's going to be 40y olds right that's
the look a lot of people wanted but
unfortunately the santis needs help is
what he needs in a complete different
area that Trump needs help with the
santis needs help selling policies Trump
needs help with a complete different
gamut of issues that he's got um brain
transplant yeah and and and we'll see
we'll see you know we'll see what's
going to happen with this uh the next
three 6 months I think A lot's going to
be we're going to learn a lot like
you're saying I'm afraid to make not
afraid but I don't want to make uh you
know predictions too early we're going
to learn a lot I think January February
probably November we'll learn on what's
going on December we'll learn what's
going on but right now they're still
going at it let me change your I know
I'm making crazy predictions by the way
and you're in that world that's why
you're 13 times New York Times
bestseller because you you say
outlandish things and people want to go
read about who hate or love you but
think about what do you think about what
happened with McCarthy speaker of the
house and G oh I'm so glad you asked
me um because I'm real I'm I'm angry
about this I I I should say I really
like Matt Gates he's incredibly
articulate I agree with him on a lot of
issues um he was utterly unfairly
smeared and I tweeted at him the day he
was doing this please don't do this
please don't do this because there are
other Republicans who aren't in like 90%
Republican districts Matt they have to
get reelected right now we have narrow
narrow the narrowest of majorities in
the house we don't have the Senate at
all and we don't have the presidency at
all so I I I want you know like Matt
Gates and the rest of these raah ra
people to watch that little cartoon they
used to have how a bill becomes law you
know okay mcarthy could have been the
most badass you want it goes and it dies
in the Senate it doesn't even get
brought up in the Senate and if it if
somehow you got the Senate to you know I
don't know have them have brain
transplants it goes to Biden and he
vetos it so I tweet at at Gates saying
your number one objective is to increase
majorities or get majorities in house
senate and win the presidency once you
have that you can do stuff like oh my
gosh build the wall okay I'm not going
back to
that um and so I was I'm angry with him
for this and then this morning at at 7
a.m. I sent out um to my substack
subscribers okay be suspicious when the
New York Times has an above the fold
this is in today's New York Times above
thefold front page article promoting
Steve Bannon oh God now let's let's ask
ourselves before we see what it is is
this going to be a good idea for
Republicans or a bad idea for
republicans and it was I was reading the
article you know obviously in in the
middle of the night I actually schedule
this to go out at whatever it was six or
seven um and what he's telling
Republicans is and he's quoted in there
I put in this substack act crazy come up
with the most outrageous amendments you
can come up with I want Total Chaos
we're going to shut down the government
shut it down I'm going to show people
shut shutdowns are great um okay what's
the biggest Advantage the Republican
party has right now we're not insane we
have Democrats pushing transgenders
poisoning and mutilating little children
they are aggressively discriminating
against white Americans they have
Unleashed opened up the Border like we
have never seen before it is creeping
into even New Yorkers are fed up with
this now they're going to they're never
going back to Sanctuary City The
Sanctuary cities are overturning it and
the Democrats will not stop they last
night I saw on and I don't even think
this was MSNBC CNN this woman was I
mostly watch watch MSNBC to the extent I
watch because they're really insane um
this woman was interviewing the first
transgender legislator who was elected
in some tiny little election in
Tennessee and I'm thinking you people
won't give up on this y you won't
stop Boys in girls Sports um Ukraine I I
don't think it's very popular right now
and I think it's going to be less
popular next year when people can't pay
their bills so what's the Republicans
brand right now
saying and Bannon is saying act insane
this will be great great woohoo war no
please please please Republicans don't
be
insane that's your uh your pitch to
Republicans versus what Bannon is saying
yes Bannon advises GOP to commit suicide
okay so McCarthy says he's not coming
back okay you said you like Gates you
like
his yeah you didn't like this uh first
time ever right this has happened is
this what they're doing to speak of the
house right Civil War and it was fairly
quick it's like fam it's like when it
got it done one who do you think is
going to replace him by the way did you
see the way you know that was pretty
solid working out he he sent everybody
home for a week too right he sent
everybody home and they're they can't
they're not going back Mt Gates still
till who do you think's going to replace
him uh you're hearing a bunch of people
are talking about you know this is an
opportunity Trump should come and be the
speaker of the house and you know you
don't have to be member of the Congress
to be this who do you think is actually
going to end up being Chosen and be the
speaker house well oddly this is
actually kind of out of my wheelhouse I
don't PID attention at that level how
important you think that position is not
very right now because we don't have um
again they have a very very very narrow
majority republ can't do anything in one
house well this is what they ought to be
doing um I won't just criticize and by
the way I'm advising this to them all
the time on Twitter and talk radio and
here what Republicans ought to be doing
in this situation again number one
objective win more seats get majorities
that's all you want to do okay so we
have lots of positions that are 8020
popular the Wall anchor babies dreamers
I say Ukraine funding but I'll give you
that's 50/50 still um boys in girl
Sports uh lots of crime issues they
could be doing anyway they should be
passing
laws passing bills rather the
Republicans can do this that are 8020
popular okay I'll give you 6040 popular
M that is so easy that is so easy um
okay get the Democrats to vote against
it send it to the Senate get the
Democrats in the Senate to vote against
it and a lot of Democrats every every
Democrat in the house is up for
reelection next year and one-third of
the Senators are and a lot of them are
going to be looking at their
re-elections and they may have to go to
their Democrat and um you know the
leader Schumer or um who whomever it is
in the house and say I got to vote for
this I'm going to lose my election so a
could actually get some laws through
because Democrats would be afraid but
worst case scenario you have all these
issues to run on this guy voted for I
don't know Boys in girls Sports and uh I
think you were very accurate in saying
like we have so much going for us if
you're the Republican party right now
you're up in all metrics across the
board who do you want to see run this
country if you're talking economy you're
talking immigration uh if you're talking
the wall that you that you've been point
out all these issues uh inflation the
gas prices Banning G stoves that one you
have all these metrics that Republicans
are pulling way ahead of of Democrats
these days talk about the sa versus
insane but let's actually unpack what's
actually happening in the house because
it looks insane right so we all remember
this was what a year ago when Matt Gates
it took 20 it took 15 different votes
how many votes Pat 15 different times
for Kevin McCarthy to become Speaker of
the House little did we know that part
of the agreement was the fact that
McCarthy agreed that just one member of
the house right would be required to
call for a vote to vacate um the office
at any time so part of the agreement
that McCarthy made with Gates was all
right if you vote for me I'm willing to
agree that if only one member of the
House comes back so this all just came
back to bite him in the ass what's my
point mhm the 80% thing Reagan we were
just in in Reagan Library in Simi Valley
I actually saw that quote I'm like oh
that's how negotiations work you're not
going to get 100% of what you want 80%
is a perfectly amazing number where does
the Republican party go from here you
know like it was eight members of the
house that sided with who the Democrats
Democrats yep okay so you had eight
Hardline magga Republicans eight of them
I think it's important to know their
names other than Matt Gates you have
Andy bigs Ken Buck Nancy mace Tim
burkette Eli crane Matt Ro rosendall and
Bob good good I've literally never heard
of one of their names other than Matt
Gates and we talk politics all the time
you have eight people you know they said
the gang of eight in the uh the
intelligence committee this is the
gang of eight in the house that
is basically tearing down the Republican
party yes you got people like n Gingrich
you have Janine Piro like going crazy on
fox saying basically the Republicans
which side are they on that's a that's
my question well new what side is new on
it's but basically is the Republican
party so invested in their morals and
resting on their laws are they cutting
off their nose despite their face doing
this oh yes oh yes yes yes yes all we
need to do is get majorities and you
just remind me of something else I don't
know the details of this but someone
very smart part of what has caused this
actually I won't even say it because
you'll yell at me um because I don't
know the name of the man I don't know
the statistical mistakes he made but
someone very smart and I ask him to send
say write it up and I'm going to
substack this um I'll tell you who it is
you know how smart he is John lot more
guns less crime um he emailed me last
night saying this whole thing in the
house is in fact Donald Trump's fault
because he put an idiot in charge of the
census he didn't know how to do it and
we lost just straight out of the shoot
seven congressional seats if we had
seven more congressional seats this
never would have happened what what
what's our majority four seats yeah what
is it 221 to 212 with two vacancies so
yeah you can't lose these types of
things so now uh does Speaker of the
House Donald Trump have a nice ring to
it what are your thoughts on that oh no
um okay I I don't want to be the one to
break this to Patrick but you can't be
speaker if you have if youve been
indicted oh damn is that how it works so
you're saying that literally he cannot
be speaker of the house because he's
literally because of the rules but I
don't think but can you be president if
you've been indicted sure you can be
elected if you've been indicted you can
be in there was I think it was um there
was a black Congressman in New York
years ago um I ought to know this I
didn't go to law school um but as I
recall he was running from for office
from prison and one election and went up
to the Supreme Court because the Supreme
Court tried to expel him or not seed him
and the Supreme Court said if that's who
the voters vote for is that him no no it
was a long timeo that is not a black
that is not a black guy I think it was
before I was born and it's a
famous black politician that's kind of
on the tip of my tongue it's not even
that important but the answer is if the
voters vote for you you can you can
serve from prison so Donald Trump
indicted cannot be speaker of the house
but could still be president United
States again except there's no possible
way he the Tex 64 style land guys that
have nominated Donald Trump for that
that is just oh Charlie Wrangle yeah
that's just a window dressing because
it's you know it's legislatively
impossible I think Kevin McCarthy got
schooled and I think he got schooled all
these guys supposedly went to law school
right and you would think Kevin McCarthy
would know the difference between a
performance clause and a unilateral
action clause he gave Matt Gates a
unilateral action clause and what a
unilateral action clause is basically
like saying your dad makes this thing if
you get straight A we're going on
vacation if you um always clean your
room you're going to get this allowance
and then he puts a unilateral action
clause at the bottom that says unless
I'm really in a bad mood one day and
I'll do none of it and that's basically
what Matt Gates put in he had all these
things in there that just said if we're
ever in a bad mood one day we can call a
vote and toss you out because we know
we'll have the Dems Plus 8 is 216 to 210
yeah that's all we need we can even have
Eli crane Arizona good guy by the way go
the other way and they thought he was
and maybe it's only five votes but we
only need one and we're going to get you
and I I feel like McCarthy was so
desperate in the middle of what have
become a media circus of electing the uh
speaker that he basically did a bad
contract and there's entrepreneurs out
there all the time that Pat and I know
this CU we're operators we don't live in
the political sphere we we live in where
we building jobs and following visions
and stuff and when you have a contract
if you get too excited at the end you
make mistakes you give in at the end
because you give to the emotion into the
deal I don't think he would have been
speaker otherwise that's the point he
was so married to speaker that no wasn't
good enough and instead he put still be
voting on that I mean I I I genuinely
hate welome right I I I Matt Gates does
a lot of great things but that was Matt
Gates's fault too it was Matt Gates who
said I will only vote president
president if you put this in and if it
hadn't been McCarthy I mean I kind of
liked that they took a while voting for
the speaker I liked it the first few
days but I would not want to have them
still voting on this this is why
Republicans need large
majorities a four vote majority and it's
going to be hell and who who are the
winners and losers here we like to do
that here this is who won this is who
lost here's who I got I'd love you to
build on this list the winners are
obviously the Democratic party here it
just proves that Democrats are real
about governing whether their policies
are ridiculous or not this is what they
want to do they want to win whereas
Republicans are like their whole Mantra
is less government less governing so
it's sort of the antithesis of the so
winning are Biden Pelosi this is a good
look for Pelosi that's never happened
under my watch never and I got one other
person Matt Gates and the gang of eight
Freedom caucus who else are the winners
and losers in your book in this
situation
well I think it's not always
because Republicans are so principled I
mean it may be I'm utterly speculating
here but because the media is so
leftwing and will'll promote the smart
Democrats and the dumb
Republicans
um Republicans it I sort of feel like
they're kind of desperate for press and
unless they get on Fox News they're so I
mean that's one of the things Bannon
said in his when he's telling them be
crazy just add amendments make sure
they're outrageous make them crazy crazy
forget Fox News you're going to come on
my podcast and okay I I I I mean it is
it is it's often a cheap shot I don't
think it's a cheap shot I understand
their point and needing to get press and
needing to get money to run I understand
that but I think that's part of the
reason they are there is a lure to be
crazy two two last questions for you
before we wrap up one what what is your
actual thoughts on Fox is Fox what it
was before has it lost its Sizzle Fox
cable is totally over cable is over or
Fox is over both I mean Fox that
Dominion
lawsuit okay how about that everything
everything you and all these drum
supporters are mad at me for saying
really how do you feel now that you know
that all of your Your Heroes on Fox News
like Tucker felt the same way saying he
hates Trump with a passion this isn't
true putting all these people on knew
that Trump had lost the election saying
all that came out and Discovery um
reminder when when you get a subpoena
you have to respond did it um so we
have what their texts and what their
emails were and there's no daylight
between what I say about Trump and what
they were saying about Trump off camera
you feel good now Trump supporters that
you were being lied to no that's that's
how much they respect the audience we're
just going to lie to you and give you
whatever you want and all the networks
are doing that now um I'm I'm friends
with Lawrence O'Donnell um we used to
have dinner in La he put me on one time
he's an MSNBC Prime so know people know
who he is um and it was like 6 months
before one of my books was coming out
and I said okay I'll do your show but I
want you to have me on when my book
comes out um you know talk about
unilateral performance
clause and he said yes absolutely he had
me on we had a great time he told me um
his mother told him it was the only time
he looked happy I mean we bickered we're
friends but he's smart I think I'm okay
um so we had a lot of fun and then he
wouldn't have me on again and why
because the audience didn't like it well
if you're going to be driven by your
audience that's why MSNBC is crazy left
that's why Fox will lie to its viewers
lie to its viewers see that's why we'll
have uh uh Stephen Schmidt last week and
the audience can get upset and next week
we'll have you on and the other side of
the audience can get upset and then next
week we'll have an athlete on and then
they're going to be confused half the
time we just like talking to people
there's something I want you to do for
me you've got to get me the clip of him
arguing with Steve Schmidt because I
can't bear to look at him I can't bear
listen to but if I can just see the clip
of you that will make me happy when we
leave you I'm and last but not least
thoughts on Tucker on tuck Tucker's
growth and what he's doing right now and
how he's exploding his shows all over
the place getting the kind of eyeballs
that he's getting what do you think
about what he's doing um no I think he's
going to go the way I ought to say I
think the only good things he ever said
on his show he he stole from May um many
and the crazy stuff about UFOs and we're
all going to die of Co you probably
don't remember that oh yeah he was the
one who drove to Mara Lago to tell the
president you've got to shut down the
country yeah got a lot of good press for
that um and January 6 was all FBI Asians
crazy um so not a fan and I think he's
going the way of of the rest of them I
mean it shows you at least it used to I
think this is changing and thanks to
podcasts like yours podcasts are so much
bigger now people are cutting cable no
one under the age of 60 only a
television set and that is so good for
the for the conservative movement
because fox has had way too much power
too long and it shows you the power of
that media real estate going back to um
um I forget some of the early ones Paula
zon Glenn Beck um Megan Kelly uh Bill
O'Reilly
Tucker once they're gone they're kind of
gone you mentioned January 6th how do
you feel meaning meaning they're done
done like no but you have you have just
been given the most wonderful you've won
a lottery ticket if you get a show at
least it used to be the case I think
this is changing on Fox news for one
thing I think they're not they're not as
interesting or smart anymore and January
6 the only thing I
mean what I think is stupid is the idea
that this was was planned by the FBI yes
there were FBI informant and I remember
going through this with all of the
terrorist ISM bust George Bush too used
to do after 9/11 every time they'd bust
there was that laana 7 and there was the
guy who was going to blow up the
Brooklyn Bridge I forget how many there
were and there was yes there were FBI
agents involved MSNBC that doesn't mean
that these guys weren't really planning
a terrorist attack and the idea that all
of those people on the mall are he to
hear Donald Trump no I don't think it's
legal incitement that's dumb but they
that was very very bad for right-wingers
I wrote a book about mobs it's called
demonic mobs are always demonic I go
through the history of American
Revolution versus French Revolution
We're the Party of of the rule of law
and the Constitution we explain no the
French Revolution they're running around
you know guillotining people and with
heads on Pikes that's the left and I
could say in that book and since that
book there has never been a right-wing
mob in the United States history that
changed on January 6th and mobs are
always bad and but and I 100% cuz these
are facts 100% cuz the capital the chief
of capital police Steph son who was
interviewed many many times but they
tried to silence him he said he as the
as the chief received the threats death
threats they were threatening
Congressman I'm not saying the FBI
planned it what what the problem with
January 6 is he knew was going down and
begged begged he called I think 17
different agencies and asked for help
but everybody denied him it's almost as
if Nancy Pelosi everybody was like they
didn't have to respond their phone
records no subpoenas no nothing his his
issue as the chief of Capitol Police who
has a higher clearance than I ever had
in the military he said he asked for
help but they didn't want to give it to
him which basically seems to me that
they were like okay we're not planning
it but if it's going to happen we're
going to make these people look like
they were really trying to take over
which I think that there there's a
there's a difference when you see it
when you see it that way in the in the
whomever's defense and by the way Trump
didn't really rush to send in the
National Guard either but in in their
defense before it happened and since it
did happen this may sound if you would
ask me before do is the capital going to
be attacked I would have said what I
just said no there's never been a
right-wing mob and the the the the the
you know warnings they got it just
sounds like of course Nancy Pelosi
didn't believe it all this Christopher
Ray the head of the FBI saying the
greatest domestic threat is white
supremacy they're just they're lying
they know it is they know
that I'm sorry white American men are
the most Pacific males who have ever
walks the face of the Earth Rob can you
pull that up what did you what was that
from PBS you put up this is what yes
this is an interview with step Sun uh
done by PBS uh where he discusses
contacting 17 different law enforcement
agencies and 1,700 officers to help
battle and they confirming that it was
correct that this happened yes and so no
I believe it yeah which which to me
which to me and if you if you really
unpack it for for him to beg begging for
help and not to get it tells me that
they they they wanted it to be bad and
they wanted because they they were
asking the National Guard all he was
begging and they never brought it to him
they were asking for weapons this is on
January 6 and on January
6th
um a according to the National Guard it
was Trump that was holding them back
they had to get Pence to make the phone
call because the National Guard wasn't
allowed to go but this I thought you
were talking about the day before and
the day before I would have said oh come
on they're not going to do and then when
they did I mean that's you we're talking
about like a few hours in there and I'm
sure a lot of people made a lot of
mistakes yeah of course but so what are
you saying exactly that this is on Trump
or this is on no I'm saying you can't
say
it's I think a lot of people made a lot
of mistakes you can't hold Trump
harmless yeah because I mean they call
it the it's every time time something
huge happens there's always an
intelligence failure they throw that
word intelligence Community they're
they're not that intelligent but it was
it was a yeah ex Gang This is this has
been fantastic and thank you for coming
out what we're going to do folks if
you're watching this we're going to put
the link below to her substack for you
to go look Rob make sure that's in the
comment section chat and description and
uh as well as the link to Amazon on any
of the 13 bestselling books you want to
buy we'll put the link below as well and
thank you so much for coming out
I really enjoyed it watched you over the
years you're you're amazing at the work
that you do you know how to get under
people's skins you're
professional and uh I know this you know
when we're sitting on talking I I
challenge on a couple different things
this is fun yeah I enjoyed it I had a
lot of fun with hopefully we do trust
that's the that's a good one put that as
a top okay gang I think we're doing uh
Tim I think we're doing Tim pool and
Jimmy door on Saturday correct 9 a.m.
Saturday there may be a surprise podcast
tomorrow and I'll tell you about it
nobody else know you and I will talk
about it afterwards okay take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye thank
you